I wasn't aware of this I mean cuz this
is a pretty great job I didn't know you
had a second job I don't have a second
job well I saw actually a local news
story this weekend from new station w JW
in Cleveland oke you often watch there
and I do
okay that pretty much is my whole
weekend
scanning local news feeds uh-huh and
don't worry folks cuz this story had a
happy ending and everyone involved is
fine now but it's a pretty great piece
of tape that I think of see Chagrin
Falls police were called to this home
Monday morning by a man who said that
while he was taking a shower his
estranged wife 33 year old Tatyana
Edwards had taken their three daughters
and left for Pennsylvania in her minivan
anytime a parent would express the
stories their children might be in
danger and it's considered a credible
threat
[Applause]
you're a policewoman there weekend
police woman I am a police woman yes
what sucks pull up that I'm just curious
how close
I have to meet this woman oh I know and
run off to a peat bog somewhere